hey 42 here welcome to what what the
most densely populated place on earth
Kowloon walled city was home to over
33,000 people all crammed into a measly
six acres it's at right in the middle of
Hong Kong Manila the capital city of the
Philippines currently holds the title of
the world's most densely populated place
but that's only because kowloon walled
city was demolished in 1994 prior to
this it held the title for over 20 years
but this Mitch massive buildings cobbled
together from scrap materials with one
of the most interesting communities on
the planet it was no ordinary swamp it's
thousands of residents lived toe-to-toe
with crime and the weird and wonderful
it was a self-sustained
city like a world within a world let's
take a trip down the alleyways of this
incredible shanty town and uncover its
secrets but first how the hell did this
happen
kowloon walled city has a long and
intricate history unlike any good tale
from history it all started out with the
British Hong Kong was ceded to the
British in 1841 as part of the Treaty of
Nanjing that ended the opium war however
China wouldn't give the British Kowloon
walled city and they held on to it
themselves for military use and they
built a wall around it hence that walled
bit the Kowloon walled city began life
as a salt trading outpost during the
Song Dynasty all the way back in ninety
and it remained a small forgotten
outpost for hundreds of years until the
British got there invasive hands on Hong
Kong as you can imagine being a tiny
Chinese owned settlement entirely
surrounded by a foreign country caused
some issues the British found the walled
city a curiosity they were bemused by it
they affectionately called it Chinese
town seriously they actually named it
this on maps of Hong Kong it became
somewhat of a tourist attraction for
British Colonials so how did it turn
into this and what happened to the war
well during World War two a mr. Japanese
occupation of Hong Kong the Japanese
demolished the stone walls of the
settlement and as to its extremely dense
population well that happened because of
a political peculiarity because Kowloon
was a Chinese nation surrounded by a
British overseas territory it was
impossible for China to police the area
and because it didn't belong to the
British they couldn't care less what
went on within its perimeter
this made Kowloon walled city
essentially lawless thousands of
refugees from the Chinese Civic war of
the 1940s came to live in Kowloon walled
city it was perfect since it was
essentially Chinese but its residents
were surrounded and protected by the
British since there were no rules or
laws people self built their own rooms
to live in wherever they could find a
space there was absolutely no order to
the place if there was a space free then
somebody was bound to come along and
build our own Kowloon penthouse there no
matter how cramped it would be and when
all the floor space was filled well they
simply built upwards all the way up to
14 stories high they would have kept
going as well if not for the nearby
airport that said they needed the
airspace above Kowloon city to be kept
empty due to airplane traffic the whole
structure is quite an impressive piece
of engineering considering it was built
by ordinary citizens they even assembled
a gigantic maze of water pipe to bring
running water into everybody's homes in
a world with no police to keep watch
crime and business flourished often as
the same entity within no time at all a
city became ruled by organized crime
syndicates the Triads the slum became
littered with endless brothels gambling
parlors and
opium dens even more disturbing is that
due to the lack of space during the day
these very same rooms were used as
schools and her salons during the nights
they were strip clubs and brothel
but it wasn't just outlets of
criminality that lines this endless
warren of hidden alleyways and
courtyards genuine businesses fragged
here as well
it became a self-sustained tightly knit
community with hundreds of shops selling
anything you could imagine hundreds of
products were manufactured within the
walls dog meats fish balls noodle makers
you name it all free to produce a stock
and sell it to the rest of Hong Kong
without any fire health or labor safety
laws but above all else it was known for
two things unlicensed dentists and
doctors due to the virtually
non-existent laws within Kowloon you
didn't need a license to set up shop as
a professional dentist or doctor which
made for some rather dubious places to
get your fillings done Hong Kong
residents who couldn't afford the high
health care costs in the actual city
went to Kowloon walled city to get it
done on the cheap which is probably not
a very smart idea considering absolutely
zero qualifications were required to
practice here conditions within this
slump weren't comfortable that's the
best of times because the accommodation
had been built so high and so unevenly
there was absolutely zero natural light
at the bottom levels and most residents
lived without sunlight 24/7 the children
would play on the roof which was
incredibly dangerous with gaps between
buildings where they had been shoved
together and endless dangerous items
protruding from the ground eventually
the filthy cramped urban maze that
thousands called home was demolished in
1993 both Britain and China mutually
agreed that it was kind of an eyesore
and they demolished Kowloon walled city
residents were given a small amount of
monetary compensation in its place now a
public garden called Kowloon walled city
park there's even a small memorial of
the Goliath structure that once was the
most inhabited six acres on earth thanks
for watching but there's a map equally
as despicable as
Hitler yet very few people even know of
his existence you may be either grossed
out when I tell you this or totally
amazed
but inside the chrysalis the caterpillar
completely liquid Isis